charged with organizing the 1964 murders
of three civil rights workers who
traveled to the south that year to
register African American voters during
the Mississippi Freedom Summer will now
show you that verdict handed down today
it's ten minutes
ladies gentlemen of the courtroom
first let me say this to the news media
before you finally are dispersed I oh
we've had our bumps and grinds so during
the trial of this case and but overall I
think you've certainly earned the
respect of all the local persons the way
you've conducted yourself if you Jones
your interest in this case but and and
I've had the opportunity to observe you
and certainly I say this to the media
you've acted as professionals and we all
have a better appreciation of you not
knowing what was involved because this
is a high-profile case and probably the
most profile profile case in the history
of this state and hopefully will not
have another casian such as this but now
thank you so much for what you found
yourself it's a difficult time it's
always a lot of feeling and emotion and
trial of any case and certainly of a
case such as this we have our rights to
be adjusted we're talking about 41 years
ago today on this anniversary and
nothing's ever happy in court
you know courts not a happy place
because we deal with problems because
we're dealing with the conduct of
someone else and decisions are made are
so important tell they're difficult
decisions on the part of the court or
part of the attorneys in the case and
the jurors themselves is a difficult
decision when they realize that whatever
they do will affect the lives or
liberties of someone regardless of what
verdict they return that we shortly
going will receive the verdict of this
jury there are 12 people who have been
chosen by these attorneys here and mr.
Killian
they have they exercised their
peremptory strikes in the selection of
these 12 jurors
and the 12 that have been chosen by the
attorneys in mr. Killian have labored no
doubt with this case it would be
absolutely wrong for those people who
have qualified as citizens of Neshoba
County for their decision to be
contested here by some demonstration
here in the courtroom recognizing that
there are victims here families of
victims recognizing that mr. Killian is
here and his family are here this is not
a place this is this is a court of
justice it's not a place for a
demonstration of emotion so I ask that
all of you take that keep that in mind
and conduct yourselves as someone who
appreciate the system itself now
whatever verdict we have in this case
whether it's a verdict of guilty or
verdict of not guilty you need to be
reminded that with all the imperfection
owed of a judicial system it has worked
whatever it is the system has performed
and I want you to be satisfied with that
because whatever that decision is
whether you're in support of mr. Killian
or whether you're in support of the
families is something that will all live
with so if you are feel that you're
incapable of restraining yourself in
emotion I'll not tolerate an outburst
I'll not tolerate any commotion the law
officers have been instructed that if
any of you should get out of hand by
showing your emotion in appreciation of
the verdict or in a disagreement with it
that you may be taken into custody and
we may have to take some punitive action
regarding that so I asked you again
please control yourself the courtroom is
not the place to do that let the record
show that we are here on this date of
this Court
the defendant is here with that ladies
and gentlemen we will receive now the
verdict of the jury would you bring in
the jury please
turn
that's fine--but come on down just a
little bit more pleasure
the record would show that all 12 jurors
in the courtroom the defendant is
present miss Vaughn you still the four
lady of the jury and miss fault has the
jury unanimously agreed to very have
unanimously agreed to a vertical all
three camps of the indictment may I see
the verdict that you
verdict that choo handed me did you
agree to the verdict that was written
here regarding count one easy did you
agree to the verdict that which had to
be regarding count one and did you ma'am
and did you agree to this very regarding
count one and did you ladies and did you
ma'am did you say agree to the regarding
count one and yes sir the record will
show that all twelve garage all polled
have stated that they agreed to the
verdict which had to be regarded count
one now with reference to count two the
verdict was handed me did you agree to
that verdict did you intended you
guesses with reference to count two all
12 jurors have stated that they agree
from the verdict that was handed me now
with reference to count three did you
agree to the verdict that was handed me
regarding count three EC and did you
ma'am did you and you ma'am yes sir
the record would show that all 30 all 12
jurors have stated that their green
verdict image had to me regarding count
three do not file the verdict but read
the verdict in count one we the jury
find the defendant Edgar a killin as to
count one guilty of manslaughter count
two where the jury find the defendant
Edgar a killing has to count two guilty
of manslaughter count three we the jury
find the defendant Edgar a killing as to
count three guilty of manslaughter now
see the bird the verdict at mrs. Lee
read regarding count one did you agree
to the verdict that was read and did you
create the verdict that was red
now did you and you yes that's a record
show that all 12 jurors stated that they
agreed the verdict is read by the clerk
now with reference to count two did you
agree to the verdict is read by Miss Lee
yes ma'am yes sir
the record we show that all 12 euro
stated their greed the verdict is read
but count to now with reference to cow
prima Smith did you agree to the verdict
that was ready yes sir well again all of
you yes sir the record of Gann was
showed that all 12 euro stated they
agreed to the verdict was read by the
clerk the reps to count 3 now if you
would mislead people come around and
collect the notebooks of the jury
mr. hood mr. mark Duncan are you two
gentlemen in agreement that we have a
unanimous verdict with reference to the
three counts of this indictment yes
y-yes mr. Moran mr. McIntyre are you in
agreement that we have a unanimous
verdict with reference to all three
counts of the indictment the defendant
wants for both periods I think
definitely umbrella that would be a
proper hour omona at this jury be
retired to the jury room please just a
bit before you are dispersed I know it's
been a trying several days for you the
court appreciates your attention and
your services
my lover sure
all persons will remain in the courtroom
our persons will be permitted to leave
until I'll make that amount
you
tonight Viet Nam's Prime Minister speaks
at a dinner here in Washington DC